[Music]
as previously noted yesterday was a big
day for performatively emotional
displays by henpecked men
during the january 6th hearing uh one
man after another took turns bawling his
eyes out
weeping openly and without shame the
most grotesque and nauseating spectacles
came as always from the politicians
here is representative adam schiff
getting uh choked up for
unclear reasons we deem elections
illegitimate merely because they didn't
go our way
rather than trying to do better the next
time god help us
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
god help us but
i have faith
because of folks like you and uh
adam i didn't expect this would be quite
so emotional either but it must be an
adam thing today
uh but i'm so grateful to all of you
and with that mr sherman i yield back uh
he's got to work on his acting a little
bit
i appreciate the timing so he timed his
emotional breakdown for
when he mentioned bigotry oh that's what
he's
we have to be nicer to people who don't
look like us
the bigotry is so upsetting to me
um so he he he timed it well but i
the the acting needs a little bit of
work he wasn't the only adam to carry on
this way adam kinzinger a republican
sobbed even louder it was an inspiring
moment
of bipartisan emasculation let's watch
that
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
my colleagues on the committee
thank you to our witnesses uh i never
expected a day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
i've talked to
a number of you and gotten to know you
i think it's important to tell you right
now though
you guys may like individually feel a
little broken
you guys all talk about the effects you
have to deal with and
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys helped
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
how we take accountability for that
and for all the overheated rhetoric
surrounding this committee
our mission is very simple let's define
the truth
and it's to ensure accountability
sorry i'm getting a little emotional too
a little misty-eyed now it goes without
saying that neither of these men have
shed any tears as we discussed earlier
for any of the victims of any of the
horrific blm riots last year
police officers were bashed over the
head with bricks beat attacked berated
this is all on video uh their precincts
were burned to the ground a retired
police officer was murdered in cold
blood and left for dead in the street
neither of the crying atoms have ever
shed any tears
for those officers by the way that
should be a band name the crying adams
um that's because their tears are fake
and manipulative fake and manipulative
tears from anyone
are disgraceful but from a man even more
so
even leaving aside the rank dishonesty
here
this is also part of a larger problem a
symptom of an endemic disease
the fact that grown men will now cry to
get what they want
like my eight-year-old daughter only
shows again that masculinity is in a
dire state in this culture
there was a time when that sort of
display would have been considered
embarrassing and weak but now we're
meant to take a man
seriously when he cries in front of us
even more seriously if anything
i think this is wrong to put him mildly
and i've said so many times
i reiterated this point on twitter
yesterday this is what i wrote simply i
said
men should not cry in public it is
unmanly and dishonorable rare exceptions
can be made to this rule
but we make far too many exceptions and
the exceptions are pretty obvious
a loved one dies your child is born your
bride is walking down the aisle at your
wedding
in the latter two cases a dignified tier
or two may be acceptable but please
don't turn the faucet on
okay there's no reason to go overboard
don't try to prove a point
um other exceptions can be imagined
we've talked about some of them before
perhaps for example
you're saying goodbye to your family
before embarking on a three-year voyage
to mars
maybe you're watching the end of the
movie rudy aside from those rare
occurrences
the point is that men should comport
themselves
with a certain level of stoicism and
dignity learning to control their
emotions
and projecting an image of strength of
someone who is composed and in control
yeah it's possible to go overboard to go
overboard in that direction
becoming an emotionless robot entirely
unaffected by suffering your own or
anyone else's
but there aren't very many men in our
society who are at any risk of falling
into that trap
the problem in most cases lies way at
the other end of the spectrum
men today are encouraged to put their
emotions on display at all times to be
vulnerable
to be soft and feminine and gentle
men are encouraged to be women in other
words in fact
some of the responses to my tweet were
pretty enlightening lots of people
of course were scoffing at the opinion
that i expressed even though it's an
opinion
shared by most people in the world
whether they'll say it out loud or not
most women naturally want a man who will
comfort
them when they cry they don't want to be
doing most of the comforting i'm not a
woman myself so i will
allow the ladies to correct me on this
point but i can't imagine that most
single women are searching for the kind
of man
who will break down in tears at the
slightest disappointment or setback
few women i'm guessing dream of the sort
of man who will come home from work
tears dripping down his cheeks sobbing
and saying
i just had a really bad day hank at the
office was super rude
i am so frustrated i would also theorize
that the typical
woman wouldn't marry a man at all if she
knew that he'd be the type
to shake her awake in the middle of the
night teary-eyed and trembling and
saying
i just heard a noise outside can you go
out and check i'm so scared
few women want men who are like this
few boys want to grow into men like this
and yet our culture produces men like
this
this may not be something that the
average person desires but it is the
agenda all the same
an agenda shared by for example a woman
named rachel barabow
she's not any great cultural force by
any means but she is a former
sportscaster turned it seems into some
kind of motivational speaker for
students and young men
i know of her existence because she
tweeted at me in response to my thoughts
about men crying and she said
two words shut up yep i've got my sassy
pants on today
we are changing the narrative on what
masculinity means despite what this guy
says
now again this is not any any any kind
of a person of any great importance but
there is something so apt about this
here is a woman who likely doesn't
represent the views of most women we
should know
but a woman all the same telling me a
man
to shut up on the subject of masculinity
and to defer
to her expertise she
not only a woman but a person who uses
the phrase sassy pants
has decided that she should be in charge
of changing the narrative on masculinity
as for me a man a husband a father of
four
i have to pipe down and allow her to
dictate terms
sadly many men have decided to obey
these kinds of demands from these kinds
of women
our culture has indeed allowed women to
take the lead even to the extent of
defining masculinity
we see this in our schools and our
churches
in hollywood and media we live in an
increasingly feminine world
though ironically men are once again
reasserting their dominance
by identifying as women and bringing
everything full circle it is a confused
situation
to say the least now into this confusion
as a way of clearing the fog a little
bit
i'd like to offer a clarifying image of
what masculinity is actually supposed to
be
and how it is supposed to act in the
world this is a story i've mentioned a
couple of times on the show but it's
worth mentioning again
um in in in this uh situation it comes
from soldier easton's uh
gulag archipelago his magnum opus about
the soviet labor camp system
in one of the volumes volume one i
believe he recounts the story of a man
who had been arrested on trumped-up
charges and shipped off to prison
and when he was at prison he was
sentenced to death but by the time the
sentence had been handed down his wife
was already on a boat
on the way to visit him and so he begged
the guards to delay his execution for a
few days so that he could see his wife
one last time they agreed
on the condition that he doesn't tell
her about his impending execution
and he didn't he was with her for three
days never mentioned it
never hinted at it uh and once she left
he was taken immediately before the
firing squad and shot
now that is stoicism and manliness
beyond the capacity of most mere mortals
but
it points us in in the direction that we
should be striving towards
we are meant as men to carry our burdens
with dignity
and not to expect everyone else least of
all the women in our lives
to lighten our loads by always sharing
in them
that at least is one way to be a man
the other is adam schiff weeping like a
school girl
using his tears to manipulate and
exploit
you could choose that option if you want
but you have to sacrifice your dignity
and your masculinity
and your self-respect in the process and
also
you are today for that reason canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated